ja also vielen Dank für die sehr netten
und sehr umfangreiche
ich gebe den dank gleich zurück an alle
die die Konferenz organisiert haben ich
war auch letztes Mal dabei und ich fand
es ein sehr schönes Format sich
auszutauschen also von daher vielen Dank
von mir dass ich dieses Jahr auch wieder
möglich ist
ich habe 2018 meinen Abschluss gemacht
hier in der LMU und die Jahre nach
meinem Abschluss waren ganz stark
geprägt davon dass ich mir bei einer
Sache ganz sicher war ich wollte auf
keinen Fall promovieren ich wollte
unterrichten wenn ich hatte immer das
Gefühl beides geht irgendwie nicht also
man muss sich so ein bisschen
entscheiden und vielleicht haben die
auch einfach die Vorbilder gefehlt und
ich könnte ganz viele Forscher und
Forscherinnen die ganz exzellent waren
dann kann ich ganz viele Dozenten die
exzellent waren aber ich kannte nur ganz
wenige die beides vereinen und die die
beides Bein haben also absoluten Helden
aber sie sagen auch immer ein bisschen
müde aus und ich glaube das ist doch
einfach so eine Zeitfrage weil natürlich
beides sehr gut zu machen bedeutet auch
irgendwie für beide Zeit zu finden das
war eine harte Jahre von meinem
doktorfahrt am Anfang für mich kann sich
dann aber ganz neue Welten aufgetragen
als mir bewusst wurde dass eben auch
Lehre Kern der Forschung sein kann und
vor allem der Einstieg über das Schiff
auf teaching and learning das kann man
öfter hier angesprochen wurde in der
Konferenz war für mich der ideale Beginn
eine auch an der Promotion weil ich eben
meinen eigenen Unterricht erforschen
konnte
so als Rahmen Bemerkung Sandra just hat
das auch schon so ein bisschen in der in
der sehr netten Begrüßung aufgezeigt
mich fasziniert einfach sehr alles was
zu dem digitalen Bereich zuzuordnen ist
ich mag es unglaublich gerne einfach
auch Sachen auszuprobieren und Lehre zu
integrieren schauen wie es funktioniert
ob es funktioniert und so weiter und ich
hatte eben auch Glück dass ich meine
Erfahrungen kurz vor Corona sammeln
konnte also während viele erstmal ganz
lang in Präsenzunterricht haben und dann
irgendwann ins digitale übergegangen
sind was bei mir so dass ich eigentlich
in der coronazeit angefangen habe zu
unterrichten und mir das dann auch eher
einen Schub gegeben hat weil ich eben
alles mitnehmen konnte was ich davor
schon ausprobiert hatte und es ist vor
allem ganz viel im Bereich Herz also
diejenigen die mich kennen wissen dass
ich mich da mit sehr intensiv
beschäftigen
und ich habe auch hier profitiert denn
2021 habe ich Förderung unterhalten
durch die virt sehr guten Bayern um für
das Hocharabische digitale Lerneinheiten
zu erstellen und eine sehen Sie jetzt
hier bereits auf der Folie und ich habe
diese Lerneinheiten jetzt nicht nur
erstellt sondern eben auch erforscht das
heißt ich habe sie in meiner eigenen
Lehre im Sommersemester 2022 eingesetzt
und gemeinsam mit den Studierenden
evaluiert und bevor ich das gemacht habe
habe ich so eine Mini Vorstufe
durchgeführt in einem laufenden
von diesem Projekt und habe den ganz
grob vorgestellt was ich machen möchte
was du der Plan ist und wollte von Ihnen
wissen was sie denn so davon halten oder
zu denken und was mir entgegen kam
warten und das ja
also man kann es noch mit Wohlwollen der
Zurückhaltung vielleicht beschreiben
aber es war auf jeden Fall keine
Begeisterung obwohl ich selber davon ja
total begeistert war weil ich davon
ausgegangen bin dass du diese Erstellung
digitaler Lerneinheiten auf das vor
arabischen total guter Weg ist denn klar
also ich sehe mich natürlich auch
irgendwie so ein bisschen als Bastlerin
im digitalen ich hatte natürlich schon
vor Augen was da entstehen soll aber wie
gesagt erst mal so vornehme
Zurückhaltung bei den studieren dazu
muss man vielleicht auch drei vorbemerkt
man machen um das zu verstehen und auch
um das einzuordnen warum sind die
Studierenden jetzt zurückhaltend ich
glaube es hängt mit drei Aspekten
zusammen zum einen wird arabisch als
schwere Sprache gesehen und um ehrlich
zu sein ich habe selber als Student
gelernt und ich fand es auch schwer und
finde es immer noch schwer ich sage auch
bis heute nicht dass ich arabisch kann
oder sagt immer noch dass sie ihre
Arbeit lerne weil das was man alles noch
nicht aneignen kann so riesig ist
dann gibt es im Hinblick auf das
arabische viele Sprachvarianten wir
unterrichten
das ist ganz einfach gesagt eher so die
die Sprache der der Medien die Sprache
der Schrift was man in Zeitungen in
Zeitschriften liest und so weiter aber
es ist nicht unbedingt das arabische was
sie auf der Straße antreffen also wenn
so eine gepflegte Konversation in Kairo
führen wollen ist hoch Arabisch zu
lernen nicht so ganz die richtige Weg
der letzte Punkt ist es gibt für
Arabisch an den Universitäten einfach
nur wenig lernen und Lehrmaterial ich
glaube im deutschsprachigen Raum sind es
ungefähr so drei Lehrbücher die zur
Verfügung stehen wo wir hier in München
nehmen genau eines davon was sonst keine
Universität verwendet also die sehen die
Auswahl ist nicht sonderlich groß das
heißt anders als wenn sie jetzt zum
Beispiel Spanisch unterrichten oder
Englisch wo sie aus dem Vollen schöpfen
bei arabisch nehmen Sie so ein bisschen
das was sie kriegen können aber wir
haben nicht wie breite Bandbreite
was ich jetzt aus meiner Sicht nicht
lösen lässt natürlich die
Sprachvarianten die bestehen einfach
aber ich bin ganz fest davon überzeugt
dass man arabisch so unterrichten kann
dass die Studierenden ist nicht sofort
von Anfang an als schwere Sprache
empfinden und aus dem Kursen flüchten
weil sie irgendwie den Eindruck haben
das können sie nicht erlernen und auch
die Sache mit dem Lernen Material ist
ein Dilemma finde ich was man angeben
kann also das lässt sich lässt sich
lösen und für mich ist gollaschek of
teaching and learning der ideale
Ausgangspunkt und jetzt eben diese
Lehrstuhl zu machen meine eigene Lehre
in den Blick zu nehmen und gemeinsam mit
den Studierenden eben diese zwei
Problemfelder anzugehen also wie kann
man das Lernen erleichtern wie kann man
eben gutes Material erstellen für die
Lehrer
jetzt ist es mir natürlich irgendwie
bewusst dass die arabische Didaktik eben
nicht ganz so am Herzen liegt wie mir
das ist bedauerlich aber verständlich
daher streiche ich aus dem Vortrag alles
aus was zu fachspezifisch ist und ich
möchte sie Stress mitnehmen und beginnt
auch zeigen erstmal was ist eine
digitale Lerneinheit wie ist sie
aufgebaut
was kann man darunter verstehen denn das
ist ein Punkt der ist übertragbar auch
alle Fachbereiche also auch wenn sie
nicht arabisch unterrichten können Sie
da vielleicht was mitnehmen und der
zweite Schritt ist dann so der große
methodische Rahmen wie habe ich diese
Lerneinheiten eingebettet in diese
lehrstudie die ich durchgeführt habe der
Rahmen ist hier das Design Base research
das finde ich ein super schöner Zugang
um Lehrmaterial zu entwickeln und auch
zu verbessern und auch das würde ich
ihnen gerne mitgeben
und als Ausblick zwei Fragen die ich
noch mal aufwerten möchte verbessert
forschen über die Lehre die Lehre und
können Studierende gute Lehre gestalten
sprich mitgestalten also so als
vielleicht zwei Ziele ich würde gerne
sie müssen mitnehmen in hafenspray in
der Lehre denn diese Lerneinheiten
Pflege erstellt und ich würde Ihnen
gerne diese Idee der lehrstudie
vorstellen auch weil ich hoffe
vielleicht darüber mit Ihnen ins
Gespräch zu kommen oder vielleicht
können Sie mir weitere Leute empfehlen
vielleicht etwas ähnliches gemacht haben
weil ich finde immer noch die Vernetzung
etwas schwieriger das teaching and
learning leidet vor allem im
deutschsprachigen Raum ein bisschen
drunter noch nicht ganz zu verbreitet
ist
gut dann mitten rein in die Lerneinheit
Sabrina jetzt würde ich Sie bitten den
Link einmal zu teilen
das ist eine digitale Lerneinheit die
ich sie für die virtuelle Hochschule
Bayern erstellt habe sind so aus und
weil ich jetzt annehme dass ich ein
bisschen langweilig wenn sie ist wenn
ich das nur erzähle erhalten Sie einen
Link in den Chat und Sie können jetzt
gerne unseren meine Präsentation
verlassen und sich eher auf diese
Internetseite mal rumtreiben da habe ich
einen lernen halt platziert ich würde
empfehlen dass Sie die maximieren und
dann sich einfach ein bisschen
durchklicken während ich hier so weiter
erzählen der Inhalt die arabische
Grammatik also kasuswelle ist für sie
jetzt nicht so relevant das ganze
natürlich vernachlässigen aber sie
kriegen einen Eindruck wie so eine
Einheit gestaltet werden kann und was
sich darin alles integrieren lässt was
Sie sehen ist jetzt ein sogenanntes
interactive book von h+p das ist sehr
ähnlich den Buch in Moodle und das
kennen Sie vielleicht bereits
eine Lerneinheit bei mir so wie ich sie
jetzt erstellt habe für die virtuelle
Hochschule Bayern umfasst immer eine
Grammatik Thema zum Beispiel tagesfälle
ist auch 45 Minuten ausgelegt also die
Studierenden des bearbeiten sollen
ungefähr 45 Minuten durchkommen und ich
habe es aufgebaut nach dem Aviva Schema
ich denke das Aviva Schema ist den
meisten ganz gut bekannten Schema aus
der Pädagogik für mich hatte ich das
sehr angeboten weil ich dadurch schaffen
konnte dass alle Lehreinheiten mit dem
gleichen Schema aufgebaut sind also
Studierende die jetzt auch mehr
bearbeiten müssen immer ganz gut wo Sie
sich gerade befinden und was jetzt zu
erwarten haben
in der Lehrer hat selber gibt es dann
Erklärungen es gibt digitale Übungen es
gibt ein Abschlusstest mir einen Blick
nochmal reinwerfen eine digitale
die Verbindung da hat man erstmal den
Text damit man informiert was ist denn
die Genitiv Verbindung dann kann man zum
Beispiel Audios einbetten wenn sie ganz
viel Zeit haben Videos einwenden aber
zeitaufwendiger und sie können zum
Beispiel Lückentexte platzieren sie
können memories erstellen also auch ganz
viel geht wirklich in den Bereich der
Gamification und hinweisen möchte ich
sie noch auf diesen blauen Button da
steht überprüfen drauf das ist was sehr
schönes und ich behaften Fee das ist
eben die Möglichkeit gibt dass
Studierende eben auch ihre eigenen
Eingaben gleich überprüfen könnten damit
auch gleich ein Feedback erhalten und
gleich wissen ob das jetzt richtig
gelöst haben oder nicht weil das ist
manchmal für Studierende etwas
unbefriedigend wenn Sie irgendwelche
Aufgaben bearbeiten aber dann kein
Feedback bekommen oder sich selber bis
zum Ende unsicher sind ob das jetzt
richtig gemacht haben
gut so viel zu Frage was ist eine
digitale Lerneinheit wenn Sie sich jetzt
noch auf der Internetseite rumtreiben
würde ich sie bitte wieder
zurückzukommen denn ich gehe jetzt auf
die nächste Folie um ihnen zu zeigen wie
ich jetzt diese Studie aufgezogen habe
der gedankliche Rahmen meiner
lehrforschung vom Sommersemester ist
nämlich aufgebaut auch dem Ansatz von
Design Base research das ist vielleicht
im ein oder anderen auch ein Begriff und
taucht relativ oft eben zusammen mit dem
scholarship of teaching and learning auf
das Konzept sehen Sie jetzt hier auf der
Folie ich habe jetzt im Schritt eins die
Lerneinheiten erstellt auch die
Erstellung schon an Studierende
gekoppelt also ich hatte ein kleines
Projektteam mit Studierenden eine ist
auch da Sabine Deininger ich wollte es
nicht alleine machen weil ich darf mein
Eindruck hatte gut Studierende eben
aktiv einzubeziehen
dann schritt 2 ist wirklich der Einsatz
im Kurs ich habe
drei evaluieren lassen also erst
eingesetzt und evaluieren lassen und
dann schließen alle Anmerkungen und das
Feedback und so weiter in ein
sogenanntes wie Design ein also man geht
gar nicht davon aus dass die dann halt
sofort perfekt sind und so können sie
angewendet werden sondern erstes
Feedback der Studierenden und die
Anmerkungen kann man sich dann noch mal
ransetzen noch mal Dinge verändern und
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich habe viel
verändert also das ging irgendwie fing
an mit der Schriftfarbe dann hätten sie
gerne noch Audios gehabt das war ein
sehr gut Hinweise die ich bekommen habe
und dadurch gibt es in den Zyklus also
das kann beliebig oft tatsächlich
passieren dass man lernt halt noch mit
überarbeitet und irgendwann kommt
hoffentlich der Punkt
optimale Design ist höre ich auch zu
verbessern sondern das ist und jetzt
bleibt erstmal so eine 5b auch noch sehr
wünschenswert das wäre dann die
Verschriftlichung der ganzen Ergebnisse
in
weil eben bei Design bestens auch der
die Idee ist dass eben Lehre auch in die
Forschung rein muss also wenn man den
Schritt 5b nicht hat ist dieses Design
Base research eigentlich nicht komplett
weil auch dann kein Austausch
stattfinden kann also wenn es nicht
verschriftliche können es andere nicht
lesen dann kann man sozusagen nicht
drüber diskutieren deswegen braucht man
auch 5b
im Sommersemester haben sich jetzt drei
lernen halten angeboten die einzusetzen
im Kurs weil es thematisch gepasst hat
das heißt es war eine dreiteilige Studie
drei festen Terminen im Semester und ich
habe jetzt eine mobility Verbindung
perfekt und Imperativ eingesetzt und
zwar in zwei verschiedenen Szenarien
also ich habe den Kurs mehr oder weniger
geteilt in die Gruppe A in die Gruppe B
Gruppe A war die Gruppe in Präsenz also
die waren auch wirklich da im Kurs ich
war da die Studierenden war da alle
hatten Laptops dabei und ich hatte
trotzdem ein bisschen die frontale Rolle
habe durch die Lerneinheit geleitet wir
haben manche Übungen gemeinsam gemacht
und habe ich sie mit dem Beamer Gewand
geworfen manche Übungen wurden in
Gruppen erledigt manche Übungen wurden
alleine gemacht aber es war synchron in
Präsenz und ich war immer
die Gruppe B fast ein bisschen
vielleicht die spannendere Gruppe die
hat das ganze asynchron vorbereitet also
die hat durch 24 Stunden Halt bekommen
und die Aufgabe war dass sie sich die
Grammatik selber aneignen die kamen dann
schon auch in den Kurs aber ich habe
nichts mehr erklärt ich bin davon
ausgegangen sie haben das selber sich
angeeignet und gemacht und verstanden
und jede der Gruppen hat anschließend
die lernen halt evaluiert in Moodle noch
mal den schriftlichen Test auch bei mir
abgelegt weil ich vor einer Gruppe Baby
wissen wollte können Sie es jetzt
wirklich oder sagen Sie nur sie haben es
gemacht und es gab immer noch einen
offenen Austausch also direkt nach dem
Einsatz der Lerneinheit wollten die
studieren auch immer mündlich noch mal
ganz viel sagen und anmerken also fast
mehr habe ich glaube ich in diesen
mündlichen Austausch erfahren als das
ist wirklich konkret jetzt in Moodle zum
Beispiel hinterlassen wurde
um sie aber einmal zu zeigen damit sie
den Einblick haben wie das aussehen
würde also in Moodle die Evaluierungen
sind ungefähr so aus also man hat dann
anonyme Kürzel ich wollte nicht den
Namen der Studierenden Wissen sondern
sollte eben anonym sagen und dann ja
oder fährt man doch nicht kleinen und
großen
dramente hat sein WLAN Schlüssel zu
Hause vergessen gehabt wusste den nicht
mehr dass ich ein bisschen schwierig
wenn man was digitales bearbeiten soll
der letzte Student Fantastischen Vier
gut weiß aber auch ein Problem hin und
so weiter also sie generieren so ganz
viel Datenmaterial was sie über Mode
tatsächlich über die feedbackfunktion
ganz gut sammeln können und das bietet
sich finde ich sehr an weil es auch für
uns Lehrende es ist lässt sich relativ
gut erschließen was man machen kann
was sie noch erhalten sind natürlich
ganz viele numerische Daten die sie dann
umwandeln können in solche Grafiken da
ich jetzt wieder davon ausgehe dass die
arabisch Didaktik ziemlich ganz so
interessiert gehe ich nicht so tief rein
aber man sieht hier zum Beispiel dass
die beiden Linien die für die beiden
Kurse stehen relativ dicht beieinander
laufen also hier lässt sich schon
erkennen dass die Studierenden ungefähr
gleich abgestimmt haben egal in welcher
Gruppe sie waren das war etwas was für
mich sehr interessant war aber das lasse
ich zur Seite weil ich einfach nicht so
relevant ist
stattdessen klar ich zurück so ein
bisschen zu der Ausgangsfrage also
verbessert jetzt forschen über die Lehre
die Lehre und ich möchte jetzt sie ein
bisschen mitnehmen was ich sonst
abschließend mitgenommen habe und dann
ich denke es könnte auch eventuell für
Sie interessant sein bzw wir können
vielleicht darüber noch mal ins Gespräch
kommen also für mich war interessant zu
sehen
dass beide lehrformate funktionieren da
ist für mich auch ganz klar die Frage zu
beantworten verbessert forschen ja auf
jeden Fall und
manche Annahmen werden einfach auch
dadurch dann widerlegt also die
Studierenden haben sich zum Beispiel
selber widerlegt wir haben ursprünglich
gesagt ne Grammatik alleine zu Hause
vorbereiten das ist ganz undenkbar und
das können wir nicht aber im Rahmen der
Lehrstelle würde ganz klar was total gut
funktioniert und ich konnte das ja auch
an den Test sehen und sie haben den
Tests geschrieben direkt sagen nachdem
sich mit der sehr Lerneinheit Grammatik
angeeignet haben und die waren genauso
gut es gab sagen konnte nicht erkennen
ja weil diese zu Hause gemacht haben wir
haben es nicht so gut gemacht deswegen
sind sie schlechter nein es hat sehr gut
funktioniert dann hat es zum Beispiel
auch gefragt
in Zukunft sollte sie lernen halten
einsetzen und wenn ja in welchem Format
jede Gruppe hat ihr eigenes Format
favorisiert also Gruppe A hat gesagt ja
unbedingt weiter ansetzen einsetzen und
bitte in Präsenz das war das beste
Format während Gruppe B gesagt hat ja
bitte unbedingt weiter einsetzen aber
wir wollen uns einfach damit weiterhin
asynchron zu Hause vorbereiten
das finde ich interessant weil es darauf
hinweist dass manches ausprobiert werden
muss also die Studierenden mögen dann
das was sie kennen weil sie eben das
andere nicht kennen also wäre es nur
konsequent vielleicht später auch der
anderen Gruppe des anderen Format mal
anzubieten damit sie dann wirklich
wählen können und auch im Hinblick
darauf was ich die Gruppe ganz am Anfang
gefragt habe können sich das vorstellen
mit diesen Lehrern halten was denken Sie
dazu wieder gesagt haben nee Grammatik
selber anhalten das wollen wir nicht
mein Eindruck ist Fragen sozusagen nach
XY macht gar keinen Sinn wenn XY nicht
bekannt ist also die Studierenden
konnten sich das nicht wirklich
vorstellen was ich damit meine dieses
man eignet sich irgendwas zu Hause
selber an und deswegen haben sie es
abgelehnt jetzt hat es einmal
ausprobiert in diesen drei Lerneinheiten
sind super zufrieden und können sich
jetzt natürlich vorstellen das heißt ich
würde mir wünschen dass auch in der
Lehre einfach Raum zum Ausprobieren gibt
dass man auch mal irgendwas probiert in
dem Seminar oder Kurs natürlich muss es
dann auch Raum dafür geben dass man
vielleicht mal scheitert also ich glaube
das ist mit allen neuen Lehrmethoden so
die wir auch im Rahmen dieses Symposiums
kennengelernt haben es kann sein dass es
super gut funktioniert kann aber auch
sein dass man das funktioniert halt gar
nicht aber das ist halt auch eine
wichtige Erkenntnis die man nur gewinnt
wenn man sich einmal macht
um der letzte Punkt ist den fand ich für
mich selber total interessant dass ich
mein eigener Blick auf meine Lehre
nochmal verändert hat also meine Lehre
wurde für mich einmal noch relevanter
also mir war der Kurs auf einmal noch
wichtiger wir waren der Kontakt zu
meinen Studierenden noch wichtiger was
noch wichtiger gut zu unterrichten weil
alles was natürlich gemacht hat jetzt
auch den Raum der Lehre überschreitet
und in meine Forschung angeht also man
wertet damit irgendwie seine eigene
Lehre auch indem man auch über seine
eigene Lehre forscht und es ist dann
halt nicht mehr so diese lästige Pflicht
ja jetzt muss ich halt noch irgendwie
lernen und hoffentlich kann ich später
dann forschen aber halt über was völlig
anderes
und auch schön zu sehen war dass die
Studierenden sich viel stärker für den
Kurs verantwortlich gefühlt haben also
dadurch dass sie gespürt haben wie hoch
die Bedeutung des Kurses für mich ist
waren sie auch eher bereit sich sehr in
diesen Kurs einzubringen
Beispiel an diesen drei Terminen der
lehrstudie war die Anwesenheit der
studieren deutlich über den Durchschnitt
also das schwankte immer so wie viele
Leute kommen wie viele Leute kommen
nicht diese groß bei den Lehrstühlen
sind tatsächlich alle gekommen und sie
waren immer vorbereitet und also dieses
alle kommen und alle sind vorbereitet
ist glaube ich so eine Kombination die
habe ich selber als sehr besonders
empfunden mich auch sehr darüber gefreut
weil es auch wirklich zeigt das ist auch
schätzen an sowas teilnehmen zu können
und dass sie natürlich auch merken dass
das Feedback was sie mir geben auf meine
Lehre direkten Einfluss hat also die
ersten Anmerkungen mit seiner
Lerneinheit konnte ich schon einarbeiten
für die letzte Lehrgang die ich
eingesetzt habe und ich denke das ist
ein Problem auch an der Uni mit diesem
Feedback Bögen also mit dem e-bassist
was wir oft am Ende des Semesters haben
wenn es halt schon ganz vorbei ist dann
dürfen die Studierenden irgendwie einmal
sagen was fanden Sie gut was fanden Sie
nicht so gut und dann ist der Kurs aber
auch schon rum so und sie merken dann
irgendwie gar nicht passiert ist noch
irgendwas mit meinen Anmerkungen oder
lohnt sich das überhaupt jemand bei der
Lehrstühle hier was einfach direkt klar
zu sehen was es für Auswirkungen hat
wenn Sie Feedback geben und wenn Sie
sich einbringen
zum letzten Punkt können Studierende
gute Lehre mitgestalten oder gestalten
ein klares Nein ich glaube man darf
nicht vergessen und ich gebe zu ich habe
das am Anfang vergessen Studierende sind
Studierende und Lehrende sind Lehrende
also als ich am Anfang dieses Projekt
Team hatte und auch die anderen
digitalprojekte davor habe ich den
Studierenden auch sehr viel Freiheit
gegeben und gesagt ja probieren Sie mal
aus machen sie mal zeigen sie es mir
dann und ich musste feststellen dass
läuft gar nicht das ist eher eine große
Überforderung und man kann auch nicht
von Studierenden erwarten das sind gute
Lehre gestalten besser finde ich eben an
den Rahmen zu geben und dann davon zu
profitieren dass man eben auch
unterschiedliche Perspektiven auf die
Lehre schaut ich habe natürlich eine
andere Perspektive auf die Lehre und
andere Dinge die mir wichtig sind als
Studierende und wir profitieren aber
natürlich davon in dem Moment wo wir uns
zusammensetzen und darüber sprechen was
ist uns wichtig an so einer Lerneinheit
was soll da rein was soll der nicht rein
und da finde ich sind die Studierenden
super wichtig dass Sie mit dabei sind
machen im Prozess der Erstellung also
wenn es geht würde ich immer dafür
plädieren da auch schon die Erstellung
eines retten aber man muss eben einen
Rahmen geben und dann kann man innerhalb
dieses Rahmens gemeinsam gestalten
wo ich aber eben einen ganz großen
Mehrwert der Studierenden sehe ist der
Austausch mit Ihnen und zwar im zweiten
und dritten Schritt von diesem Design
Base research sie erinnern sich bei der
Anwendung und dann auch bei der
Evaluierung denn also ich glaube so gute
Lehre ohne die Studierenden zu gestalten
ist völlig unmöglich weil natürlich
mache ich immer irgendwas von dem ich
denke dass das beste was man machen kann
und das müssen sie lieben und das ist
didaktisch total sinnvoll aber ohne das
Feedback der Studierenden ohne dass mir
sagen was sie jetzt eigentlich brauchen
kann ich keine gute Lehre entwickeln das
ist wirklich was was nur gemeinsam geht
und ich fand es jetzt schön so im Rahmen
dieser Lehrstuhl die ich mal
durchgeführt habe zu sehen wohin man
eigentlich kommt wenn man sowas
gemeinsam macht von freue ich mich auch
sehr darauf was auch mal wieder zu
machen also es ist sehr viel Aufwand
also man muss ein bisschen gucken dass
das nicht irgendwie zu oft macht man
muss auch was machen mit dem ganzen
Infos aber es hat meine eigene Lehre
sehr verbessert Unterrichtsklima sehr
verbessert ich finde es sehr viel
Positives raus entstanden was jetzt auch
noch weitere
und damit schließe ich mich äh ich war
mit schließlich und freue mich sehr auf
Ihre Anregungen und Gedanken und das wir
noch ein bisschen in die Diskussion
kommen danke schön